pourquoi est ce que tu fais ton ordi
chaque fois que j'ai rappliquent
tu
as l'air stressé
[Musique]
c'est un peu la folie au boulot
j'ai toujours voulu changer le monde
comment
amazon
pour la drogue sauf qu'on peut pas
acheter de drogue sur internet et
schiste est possible
je vais me faire 75000 dollars en
bitcoin
en une heure et demie
ça fait un million deux par jour
ce mec c'est le premier millennials de
chant
vous avez la résoudre à l'ancien agent
bowden
tout ce qu'ils savent ils l'ont appris
sur un écran
ils se sont jamais fait partie de leur
vie
l'expérience est primordiale tant
est que vous l'aurez attraper envoyez
moi un fax
le darknet un arrivée spécial dans ma
boîte aux lettres
règles sont en train de changer ça va
arroser tous les quartiers d'amérique
ce site web n'est qu'un vulgaire du fait
que nous ont enfermés
non
c'est moi qui ai réussir au final à
faire tomber ce connard
situe saute le pas
tu pourras plus jamais revenir en
arrière
devient obsessionnel qui croire
qu'ils en arrivent à le faire tomber
pour complicité de meurtre échec et mat
tiens ta respiration
qu'est ce que tu fous avec mon pognon
le site nous survivra à tous